whether you're in it for the bottomless
mimosas the decadent pancakes or the
avocado toast brunch is hands-down the
best part of the weekend while enjoying
the finer things in life did you ever
stop to think about how this glorious
seed to the heat again well it all
started with a man a man with a hangover
back in 1895 there was this guy named
well guy and he was a writer living in
England at that time sundays were a big
deal an early post church meat heavy
meals were all the rage but for those
nursing a hangover and recovering from
the previous night's debauchery those
meals weren't always appetizing so guy
proposed a compromise and penned a
prolific essay appropriately named
brunch ugly he envisioned a hybrid meal
of sorts that was lighter than the
typical meat spread and included a
variety of pastries friends could gossip
about the previous night's indiscretions
while chasing their hangovers with some
hair of the dog but the delicious
British invention took what seems like
forever 30 years to cut down in the
state when it did
Sunday morning never looked the same
again so the next time you're enjoying a
french toast taped by a Bloody Mary take
a second to thank the hard drinking
Englishmen by the name of guy
[Music]